pertinence de la haine de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure sénateur centriste de
l'Essonne vice-président du Sénat
rapporteur de la commission d'enquête
sur les concessions autoroutières on va
en parler dans quelques instants mais
d'abord dans l'actualité on a appris que
la Haute Autorité de Santé avait donné
un avis favorable pour le vélo
obligation de vaccination des soignants
François brode le ministre de la Santé a
dit qu'il suivrait cet avis est-ce que
vous êtes satisfait je pense que c'est
une bonne chose on manque de soignants
il y a beaucoup de personnes qui sont en
difficulté parce que elles ont pas voulu
être vaccinées aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est très bien de les réintégrer il
faut les réintégrer immédiatement je
pense
l'autre sujet d'actualité on l'a vu
c'est ce plan o présenté hier par
Emmanuel Macron quelques jours après la
manifestation anti-bacine à
Sainte-Soline Emmanuel Macron a dit hier
qu'il validait l'utilité de sébacine
tout en disant vouloir mieux répartir
les usagers aussi votre position oui
écoutez de toute façon l'eau c'est un
sujet
mondial c'est pas un sujet uniquement
franco-français comme l'énergie c'est
une ressource qu'il faut à laquelle il
faut faire attention donc c'est bien
d'en parler beaucoup c'est bien de je
pense que les objectifs d'économie qui
sont annoncés sont aussi
atteignables à mon avis à condition que
effectivement on en parle qu'on dit face
attention qu'on laisse aussi les
territoires gérés au plus près les
ressources parce que ça c'est quelque
chose auquel on est très attaché ici au
Sénat c'est la différenciation du
traitement
il y avait notamment un élément qui
était l'obligation de transférer en 2026
l'eau et l'assainissement qui est ce qui
est toujours dans la loi aujourd'hui et
ce qu'on souhaite faire évoluer pour
laisser la possibilité de s'organiser au
niveau local comme on le souhaite et pas
avec des obligations forcément et je
pense que c'est la meilleure le meilleur
moyen qu'on aura pour effectivement
mieux gérer cette ressource il a dit
qu'il allait aider les collectivités à
faire face aux fuites d'eau dans les
canalisations qui font gaspiller
énormément d'eau il a eu raison le chef
de l'État il faut donner de l'aide aux
collectivités là-dessus ou est-ce qu'il
faut augmenter le prix de l'eau en tout
cas il faut il faut il faut bien sûr
aider les collectivités il faut éviter
de le retirer des ressources parce que
finalement on nous retire pas mal de
ressources et on nous empêche d'être
autonome sur le plan fiscal donc ce qui
est gênant moi je pense que c'est très
bien alors sur l'eau moi je suis très
attaché à la désalini désalinisation
dessaler l'eau de mer ça c'est quelque
chose d'important alors peut-être qu'en
France c'est peut-être un peu difficile
mais moi je suis sur un projet de
dessalement de l'eau de mer avec
l'énergie solaire et ça c'est ça qui est
important parce que tout ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui c'est très énergétique or et
on pourrait avoir des systèmes qui
soient strictement autonomes avec
l'énergie solaire et qui permettrait de
dessaler l'eau de mer et ça je pense que
ça serait une solution j'ai pas que ça
serait le Graal mais pas très loin en
tout cas sur le dans le domaine de l'eau
donc c'est un sujet sur lequel je
travaille beaucoup ça fait ça fait 5 ans
avec un ami et on espère pouvoir
déboucher sur le sujet l'échéance oh
écoutez il nous faut encore au moins à
mon avis 5 5 à 10 ans mais ça laisse
encore du temps mais en tout cas ça
serait une solution qui est qui serait
très intéressante non seulement pour la
France mais aussi pour beaucoup d'autres
pays Emmanuel Macron souhaite la mise en
place d'un tarif progressif de l'eau
pour les Français c'est-à-dire qu'il y
aurait une base et après ce qu'il
appelle la consommation de confort plus
vous consommez plus vous payez c'est une
bonne chose oui c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas bien non plus parce que c'est
vrai quand on remplit une piscine on
utilise beaucoup d'eau et c'est pas
normal de payer un peu plus que le
consommateur lambda je dirais qui qui se
douche qui qui boit l'eau du robinet ça
ça me paraît ça me paraît quelque chose
d'assez de est-ce que je vous propose ma
question tout à l'heure est-ce que l'eau
aujourd'hui est trop peu cher en france
est-ce qu'il faut accepter de payer plus
cher l'eau L'eau est pas cher l'eau est
pas cher et c'est vrai que quand moi il
m'est arrivé de diminuer des taxes sur
l'eau un des taxes d'assainissement sur
l'eau en fait personne ne sont aperçoit
donc vous avez du mal vous a donné le
chiffre du prix de l'eau aujourd'hui
vous savez pas dans votre commune et en
fait le prix du mètre cube d'eau est
très faible et souvent les gens achètent
de l'eau de
l'eau minéralisée mais en réalité l'eau
du robinet est très très peu cher donc
honnêtement c'est c'est un sujet sur
lequel on peut effectivement travailler
à la fois sur la progressivité et
peut-être sur le prix de base aussi des
il y aura pas de défense supplémentaires
demandés aux agriculteurs qui resteront
à prélèvement constant est-ce que le
chef de l'État est raison de préserver
les ingrédients ont été pas mal
sollicités ces dernières années avec
beaucoup de contraintes supplémentaires
et on a un monde agricole qui souffre
donc c'était une grande force
l'agriculture en France on est
aujourd'hui dans une situation qui est
compliquée donc je pense que c'est bien
effectivement de déménager
plus Emmanuel Macron qui a été un peu
chahuté lors de ce déplacement vous
l'avez vu dans le journal avec l'annonce
de ce plan o il a voulu il voulait en
tout cas tourner la page de la réforme
des retraites il a dit le pays doit
continuer à avancer vous approuvez ça
est-ce qu'on peut enjamber la crise
sociale en ce moment en tout cas en tout
cas il faut je sais pas s'il faut
l'enjamber en tout cas il faut la
prendre en compte mais ça ne veut pas
dire qu'on traite aucun autre sujet moi
j'ai protesté pendant la crise sanitaire
sur le fait que on parlait que la crise
sanitaire qu'on ne faisait rien d'autre
moi je pense que c'est pas c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible pour un pays
de ne parler que d'une seule chose qu'on
traite un sujet à fond et il faut le
traiter sur le sujet des retraites il va
revenir sur la table je vais vous dire
c'est pas même la réforme qui est pour
l'instant adoptée par le Parlement et
pas suffisante pour remettre les les
comptes les contes à jour
on est en train de laisser des dettes
considérables aux jeunes générations
donc moi à limite je peux me dire je
m'en fiche un petit peu mais je peux pas
vis-à-vis de mes enfants vis-à-vis des
nouvelles générations je peux pas leur
dire
chaque année les retraites ça nous coûte
60 milliards là ça va nous faire
peut-être deux trois milliards en moins
mais honnêtement on reste encore on
charge les générations futures pour bien
vivre aujourd'hui moi pour moi c'est pas
moral mais ça veut dire que cette
réforme elle ne va pas assez loin pour
vous pour moi il va passer loin il
aurait fallu quoi alors moi j'aurais
fait une réforme un peu différente
puisque moi j'aurais pas parlé de d'âge
j'aurais parlé de nombre de trimestres
nombre de trimestres cotisés ça veut
dire que quand vous commencez tôt vous
partez tôt quand vous commencez tard
vous partez tard ça me semble beaucoup
plus juste il fallait passer à combien
parce que là on va arriver à 172 43
annuités pour vous il fait les arrivées
il faut recalculer mais pour moi ce qui
serait normal c'est que le régime des
retraites soit à l'équilibre et il faut
44 45 à nuit honnêtement je je sais pas
il faudrait le recalculer par rapport au
moins j'ai pas le calcul en tête et vous
savez c'est un sujet très complexe donc
il y a pas beaucoup de personnes qui le
maîtrisent très très bien donc il faut
se pencher sur le sujet à fond
il y a d'autres sujets il y a la
organisation par exemple la
capitalisation il y a un certain nombre
de Français qui ont bénéficient
notamment les fonctionnaires et il y a
beaucoup de Français qui peuvent pas en
bénéficier je trouve ça très dommage
donc il faudrait à côté de la
répartition qu'on souhaite préserver il
faut aussi de la capitalisation et c'est
un sujet qu'on a pas du tout abordé un
système mixte
abordé alors on l'a pas abordé aussi de
la faute du gouvernement parce que il a
choisi un
mode de vote et de loi qui était une loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale et
en fait c'est vrai qu'on aurait bien
aimé avoir une loi sur les retraites
complètes et qui nous permettent aussi
d'aborder ce sujet de la capitalisation
vous êtes inquiète du climat social
aujourd'hui ecoutez ne pas être inquiet
ça serait complètement indifférent je
pense que il y a un climat quand même de
violence élevées au niveau on le voit
bien au niveau de la rue des
protestations il faut arriver à
retrouver de la sérénité parce que on
peut pas débattre correctement sans
sérénité et comment on fait pour trouver
cette sérénité je pense que c'est
forcément le dialogue donc la première
ministre a souhaité réouvrir le dialogue
avec les syndicats je pense que c'est
indispensable après est-ce que ça sera
suffisant c'est pas forcément parce que
dans ce dialogue avec les syndicats
parce que c'est un petit peu le point de
désaccord entre eux est-ce qu'il faut
reparler de cette réforme des retraites
est-ce qu'il faut red dialoguer sur le
report de l'âge
si j'étais Premier ministre ce que je ne
suis pas et si j'étais Premier ministre
je permettrai de rouvrir aussi ce
dossier là parce que je pense qu'il est
loin d'être fermé je pense que c'est pas
la réforme qui est qui est là ne suffit
pas à régler le problème de la retraite
ce que je viens de vous dire
ils ne veulent pas d'un rapport de l'âge
à la façon de 4 ans est-ce que pour vous
il faut accéder à cette demande non mais
pour pour moi c'est pas une histoire
d'âge comme je vous l'ai dit c'est
plutôt les histoires de trimestre c'est
pour te c'est plutôt une histoire de
trimestre donc on est syndicats c'est
une histoire d'âge qu'est-ce qu'il faut
leur dire
moi personnellement je leur dirais que
l'âge c'est pas ce qui est important ce
qui est important c'est le nombre de
trimestres et d'avoir une réforme juste
qui puisse
compliqué la réforme juste parce que en
fait vous avez des situations qui sont
aujourd'hui très différentes entre les
Français avant il y avait des carrières
qui étaient longues et assez stable
aujourd'hui on a des interruptions on a
des gens qui cotisent pas pendant un
moment qui donc tout ça c'est compliqué
il faut pas non plus que entre une
personne qui a presque jamais cotisé et
celle qui a cotisé tout le temps il y a
pas beaucoup de différence il faut qu'il
y ait de la différence à la fin donc
parce que sinon ça sert à rien de
cotiser et voilà donc tout ça c'est
c'est compliqué mais ça nécessite qu'on
continue le dialogue et en tout cas
qu'on leur ouvre parce qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement il est un peu en panne
alors elle va rencontrer les les
syndicats vous l'avez dit elle elle
valait également prévu de rencontrer les
partis politiques euh la semaine
prochaine la France insoumise et les
communistes ont dit qu'il n'irait pas
vous comprenez leur position non je
pense que tout le monde doit être ouvert
au dialogue c'est pas en protestant
comme ils l'ont fait à l'Assemblée
nationale de façon à mon avis pas
approprié du tout par rapport à
l'institution je pense pas que ça soit
de cette façon là qu'on arrive à faire
avancer le pays ni en faisant de
l'obstruction en permanence il faut il
faut dialoguer on n'a pas toujours
raison personne n'a totalement raison ni
le gouvernement ni les syndicat ni
moi-même mais à un moment donné c'est
par le dialogue qu'on permet qu'on peut
avancer donc il faut que chacun avance
ses arguments moi j'en avance un certain
nombre mais je pense qu'il faut il faut
que tout le monde les avance et qu'on
soit qu'on essaie de se mettre d'accord
sur un diagnostic et après ben voilà sur
les pistes pour pour atteindre
l'objectif mais eux ils disent on veut
pas rencontrer les abeilles de bord on
va rencontrer Emmanuel Macron ils
appellent à une marche vers l'Élysée
moi je pense que c'est le premier
ministre qui détermine et qui conduit
l'action du gouvernement et la politique
le président normalement il devrait être
un peu plus en retrait c'est les
institutions de la 5ème République alors
parfois dans la pratique ça n'a pas été
le cas mais on devrait aujourd'hui
retrouver un peu cela ça ferait ça
ferait du bien la démocratie française
de un peu de clarté et il faut arrêter
de tout centrer sur le seul président de
la République on va voir l'actualité
dans nos régions on va du côté de
Strasbourg on retrouve Frédéric vésar
bonjour Frédéric merci beaucoup d'être
avec nos rédacteurs en chef des
rédactions des Dernières Nouvelles
d'Alsace et de l'Alsace et alors avec
vous on va parler d'un autre sujet mais
qui est peut-être aussi lié à la colère
des Français c'est la flambée des prix
notamment la flambée des prix de
l'électricité
alors flambée des prix d'électricité et
et du gaz et en fait alors là on est sur
un autre terrain que celui des
entreprises on a effectivement publié ce
matin un article sur une entreprise qui
s'appelle Velcorex alors que connaissait
peut-être pas que c'est une entreprise
c'est la dernière entreprise en France
qui produit du velours voilà qui est
situé dans une vallée des Vosges qui
bosse pas mal pour l'industrie du luxe
et cette entreprise en fait a vu sa
facture d'électricité et de gaz
exploser
déjà l'année dernière et encore plus
cette année puisque le coût de
production le coût énergétique de
production d'un mètre de tissus était
multiplié par 5 entre entre 2022 et 2023
c'est une PME qui compte quelques
quelques centaines de salariés et elle a
droit pour l'instant aucun aucun soutien
sur le plan énergétique l'Assemblée
nationale a voté
une loi qui permet d'établir justement
le retour des tarifs réglementés pour
les entreprises de moins de 5000
salariés
cette loi va arriver au Sénat le 6 avril
je suis bien compris hier il y a eu la
visite dans cette entreprise d'une d'une
députée les filles qui soutient cette
cette proposition de loi et et toute une
série d'amendements pour protéger
justement les entreprises locales donc
ça m'intéresserait d'avoir la position
de Monsieur de La Haye sur sur le sujet
d'abord est-ce qu'il va voter cette
cette loi et est-ce que c'est selon lui
suffisant et qu'elle a pas que ça peut
avoir justement aussi sur l'équilibre
budgétaire
je n'ai pas encore vu donc je peux pas
vous dire si je vais la voter ou pas en
tout cas moi je suis pour un soutien aux
entreprises qui dépendent beaucoup de
l'énergie et je suis aussi pour une
déconnexion du prix de l'électricité par
rapport au prix du gaz parce que on a
une logique là de fixation des prix qui
est ce sur l'électricité qui est une
aberration on n'est pas du tout en lien
avec le coût de production et on a des
choses qui varient d'une façon
considérable et moi je regarde aussi
beaucoup c'est que le prix du gaz a
baissé a quand même pas mal baissé
depuis son plus haut et on n'a pas
l'impression que ça se répercute encore
beaucoup sur les consommateurs donc on a
l'impression comme un peu l'essence qu'à
chaque fois que ça augmente ça augmente
très vite et quand ça baisse ça baisse
beaucoup moins vite donc c'est vrai
qu'il y a un vrai sujet en tout cas et
et un vrai sujet de soutien quand même
de notre industrie et de nos entreprises
qui fonctionnent bien et il faut
absolument que sur ce sujet là on est
alors je sais pas si la proposition de
loi permet de le traiter complètement
mais si elle le permet moi je je la vois
très volontiers
alors il y a un autre aspect dans cette
proposition de loi en complément alors
ça c'est je crois c'est un abonnement
qui est porté plutôt par la par la
gauche qui serait l'idée de mettre une
taxation verte sur les produits importés
précisément dans le cas de cette de ce
textile justement ils sont soumis
notamment à une conférence importante
notamment des producteurs Turcs qui
n'ont pas de contraintes en termes de
traitement de l'eau enfin voilà il y a
tout un tas de normes qui n'existent pas
et qui sont réservés à la France et à
lieu est-ce que vous défavorable à une
telle une telle taxation en tout cas je
suis favorable à ce qui est une équité
effectivement et que à partir du moment
où on se met des contraintes sur notre
territoire qu'on les impose
effectivement aux autres parce qu'il y a
pas de raison effectivement qu'on
apporte des produits et c'est vrai on
agriculture aussi on parlait de
l'agriculture tout à l'heure et on a
l'impression que on met beaucoup de
contraintes sur nos agriculteurs et que
par ailleurs on apporte des produits qui
eux ne sont pas soumis à ces contraintes
là donc si on veut vraiment que ça soit
équitable il faut trouver le moyen et ça
peut être par une taxe même si je suis
pas toujours favorable à augmenter le
nombre de taxes et à partir dans tous
les sens mais là en l'occurrence ça peut
être une taxe qui a un vrai objet
de justice et d'équité merci beaucoup
Frédéric visard d'avoir été avec nous
regarde vos deux une les deux consacrées
au plan haut d'Emmanuel Macron manque
d'eau le plan de Macron elle a une des
Dernières Nouvelles d'Alsace et le plan
d'urgence sur l'eau de Macron c'est à la
Une de l'Alsace merci beaucoup Frédéric
lézard d'avoir été avec nous on va
parler de l'actualité du Sénat content
va nous rejoindre ce que vous avez
beaucoup travaillé au Sénat sur la
question des concessions autoroutières
Vincent delaelle est arrivée des péages
ont augmenté le mois dernier les
présidents des sociétés d'autoroute
était auditionnées au Sénat cette
semaine vous aussi d'ailleurs on en
parle tout de suite avec notre
journaliste parlementaire quand un câble
[Musique]
bonjour Quentin bonjour Oriane bonjour
Vincent Delahaye et Quentin le CNA s'en
part à nouveau du sujet des concessions
autoritaires voilà c'est un nouveau
cycle d'audition effectivement qui s'est
ouvert cette semaine mais c'est vrai que
dès 2015 les sénateurs avaient travaillé
sur ce sujet au moment de la
renégociation des concessions puis à
nouveau en 2020 avec une commission
d'enquête Vincent Delahaye vous en étiez
le rapporteur vous commencez à
comprendre la mécanique autour de la
privatisation des autoroutes et aussi
ses dérives et dernier épisode en date
il remonte à février dernier
des péages ont encore augmenté plus
4,75% en moyenne c'est une augmentation
record comparée aux 2 % de 2022 0,4% en
2021 des hausses alors que les sociétés
d'autoroute affichent des profits
records Oriane les 25 sociétés
d'autoroute ont vu leur bénéfices net
augmenter de plus 47% pour atteindre 3,9
milliards en 2021 et de cette question
est-ce que lors de la privatisation des
autoroutes en 2006 les contrats ont-ils
été mal ficelés et ben voilà c'est toute
la question effectivement c'est ce que
vous essayez de comprendre aussi le
gouvernement de l'époque et les suivants
lorsque ces contrats ont été prolongés
c'est gouvernants n'ont-ils pas fait de
gros cadeaux à ces sociétés privées les
critères retenus pour calculer la
rentabilité de sa société n'était pas
bon je cite là le ministre de l'Économie
la semaine dernière en audition à
l'Assemblée nationale et c'est vraiment
là le nerf de la guerre vous avez
bataillé vous Vincent Delahaye pour
comprendre comment était construit les
modèles économiques des contrats et
elles sont c'est très obscu c'est tout
ça et privé vous le dites certaines
sociétés sont beaucoup plus rentables
que ce qui était prévu et selon le
président de Vinci autoroute qui était
donc au lycée auditionner cette semaine
il faut prendre des pincettes avec ces
chiffres on l'écoute
je sais bien que les montants qui sont
en jeu
surprennent une concession c'est un
instrument de financement et que c'est
une société à durée déterminée durée
pendant laquelle on est réputé
rembourser l'investissement initial au
début on perd de l'argent c'est la
fameuse courbegie au début on perd de
l'argent et à la fin on gagne dans les
profits des dernières années de la
concession de quoi compenser les
investissements initiaux on est
exactement dans les termes du modèle tel
qu'il avait été contractualisé au moment
de la privatisation alors voilà pour le
président de Vinci Autoroutes Vincent
Delahaye la privatisation elle date de
2006 une question toute simple est-ce
qu'il y a eu des abus autour de ces
contrats
de tous ces contrats on n'a pas de voilà
de visibilité exactement sur comment il
fonctionne ces contrats vous ça a été un
de vos un de vos de grands combats
c'était de refaire le calcul
mathématique de de ces contrats c'est
bien ça voilà si j'avais écouté les
sociétés d'autoroute ont publié au cas
chiffres donc on a fait nos propres
chiffres au Sénat et donc ceux qui
veulent dire le rapport du Sénat ils ont
les prévisions jusqu'en 2036 pour chaque
société et à partir de là on a pu on
peut évaluer une rentabilité sur la
durée du contrat parce que si vous
écoutez aussi nos interlocuteurs eux ils
vous disent attendez la fin du contrat
et on vous dirait qu'elle a été la
rentabilité donc nous nous on a fait des
prévisions ces prévisions moi comme j'ai
pu voir celle des sociétés d'autoroute
je peux vous dire qu'elles sont en phase
même si c'est pas leur chiffre
précisément c'est les nôtres ce qui nous
a permis de les publier et aujourd'hui
moi je les mets à jour chaque année et
chaque année on constate que on est dans
les clous on est dans les toutes nos
prévisions oui et vous dites il y a des
surprofits par rapport à ce qui était
prévu lorsqu'il y a eu cette
privatisation c'est bien ça 30 à 35
milliards d'ici la fin des contrat et
c'est ce montant là qu'il faut pouvoir
rediscuter très largement pour voir
comment la collectivité et les usagers
peuvent en bénéficier et l'augmentation
de 4,75% des tarifs alors on va vous
dire aussi que c'est février il faut pas
bouger une virgule du contrat c'est le
contrat mais ça augmente les profits des
sociétés d'autoroute de 300 millions par
an donc d'ici la fin des contrats c'est
systématiquement 300 millions donc c'est
pas justifié c'est pas justifié
honnêtement c'est c'est énorme ça
compense ça fait beaucoup plus que
compenser les surcoûts d'inflation donc
à un moment donné c'est pas normal qu'on
continue à ponctionner comme cela les
automobilistes alors qu'il y a pas de
justification profonde donc après il
faut il faut trouver les moyens moi je
suis pas pour supprimer les péages je
suis pas pour les autoroutes gratuites
comme en Espagne je pense que c'est très
mauvais d'abord c'est le contribuable
qui paye il y a jamais rien de gratuit
et ensuite ça serait favorisé les gens
qui viennent qui traversent la France
notamment et qui paierait pas de
l'autoroute alors du coup c'est quoi
vous votre message de ce qu'on comprend
c'est quoi il faut que l'État est bien
mettre la pression sur ces sociétés
d'autoroute et peut-être qu'elle
contribue davantage au développement du
réseau ferré à l'intermodulate modalité
c'est ça il faut inverser le rapport de
force aujourd'hui le rapport de force
est en faveur des sociétés d'autoroute
il faut que ça soit à la puissance
publique qui est aussi un rapport de
force en tous les cas il faut à minimax
que ça soit équilibré et le fait d'en
parler qu'on en ait parlé au Sénat qu'on
continue en parler puisqu'il y a une
commission qui vient de se saisir du
dossier et que les médias comme le vôtre
en parle ça participe effectivement du
l'inversion du rapport de force et il
faut absolument que le Conseil
d'enquêter l'état puisse discuter avec
des soucis des autoroutes les obliger à
venir autour de la table et à discuter
au fond de ces contrats qui ne sont pas
adaptés à une vraie concession de
service public mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait
du coup est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on peut
avancer la fin de ces contrats sans que
ça coûte trop cher à l'État alors moi je
pense que on pourrait même on pourrait
même rompre les contrats
par exemple pour Vinci moi je considère
qu'à fin 2023 ils ont atteint les 8%
qu'ils attendaient au début 8% de
rentabilité c'est quand même pas mal sur
leur investissement et c'est à partir du
moment où ils sont assez huit pour cent
on peut considérer qu'on pourrait
romproser contrats alors il est prévu
jusqu'en 2030 36
le gouvernement par le biais de Bruno Le
Maire évoque la possibilité de
raccourcir ses contrats depuis que ça
soit pas 2036 mais que ça soit par homme
2030 je pense que c'est une piste qui
peut être suivie et en tout cas ils ont
interrogé le Conseil d'État on va suivre
ce que va dire le Conseil d'État mais je
pense qu'il faut continuer à en parler
beaucoup de façon à ce qu'on puisse
avancer et qu'on arrête le statut quo
les sociétés d'autoroutes elle elles
veulent ne pas en parler pour vivre
heureux vivement caché c'est leur devise
c'est pas la même mais vous dites il
faut inverser le rapport de force est-ce
que le gouvernement Bruno Le Maire
Clément bonne en font assez la tu es ce
qu'ils arrivent à l'inverser ce rapport
de force ça commence un petit peu ça
commence en tout cas moi pour moi pas
assez moi je pense qu'il faut aller plus
loin qu'il faut avoir encore plus de
volonté mais en tout cas on commence à
dans le discours en tout cas dans le
discours du gouvernement on entend des
inflexions importantes et se positionne
visiblement sur des conclusions que l'on
a fait aussi dans notre rapport donc
tant mieux je dis tant mieux maintenant
c'est pas suffisant il va falloir des
actes est-ce qu'il faut aller jusqu'à
renationaliser est-ce que l'État a les
moyens de reprendre tout ça à sa charge
moi je pense qu'il faut pas nationaliser
parce que l'État si vous me citez un
service ou une infrastructure qui est
bien géré par l'État je serai ravi de
vous entendre mais je pense que les
sociétés privées sont compétentes donc
on a des groupes comme Vinci comme
Eiffage qui sont très compétents donc il
y a il faut pas il faut s'en servir il
faut s'en servir mais on les accabant
une bonne concession c'est un bon
contrat et un bon suivi et ça
aujourd'hui on les a pas forcément on a
un meilleur suivi mais on n'a pas encore
un bon contrat oui qu'est-ce que vous
dites aux automobilistes qui voient ces
prix qui explosent sur les autoroutes
qu'est-ce que vous voulez en dites c'est
français qui peuvent être dégoûtés de la
situation actuelle et je leur dis que il
faut continuer à faire pression pour que
les choses évoluent et évoluent le plus
vite possible on parlait tout à l'heure
retraite oh mais il y a d'autres sujets
les autoroutes c'est un autre sujet
qu'il faut traiter et donc il faut il
faut que tout le monde prenne conscience
qu'effectivement il y a une évolution
nécessaire indispensable qui sera
profitable aux automobilistes comme au
gouvernement et à l'état donc on a tous
intérêt à attirer dans le même sens
c'est pas contre les sociétés
d'autoroute parce qu'il s'agit pas de
dire on est contre les sociétés aux
autres moi je suis pour avoir des
groupes français qui fonctionnent bien
mais après il faut qu'il soit bien
encadré merci à tout à l'heure dans le
club oui on reviendra sur la visite
d'Emmanuel Macron dans les Hautes-Alpes
ouais effectivement on va on va en
parler dans 20 minutes dans le club de
cette visite d'Emmanuel Macron dans les
Hautes-Alpes il a présenté le plan haut
mais évidemment il a été rattrapé par la
contestation sur la réforme des
retraites alors va-t-elle empoisonner la
fin de son quinquennat ce sera le débat
du club merci beaucoup Vincent Delahaye
merci à vous d'avoir été avec nous on va
parler d'un autre sujet on va parler de
la fin de vie tout de suite avec notre
prochaine invité Claude grange qui nous
rejoint